[Music]
let's go to chris in pennsylvania what's
up chris
hey how you doing remarkable how about
you
i'm doing all right
what's up dude i can help
yeah so i have a question for you uh
my wife and i we both have lost our
previous spouses
wow how old are you
i am 38.
and my wife is 35. oh my gosh man i'm so
sorry to hear that for both of you
thanks man how long how long ago for
both of you
uh
hers was
she lost him about eight years ago
and one is going to be eight years here
in january
all right wow okay uh we have three kids
three girls
um i'm a hashtag girl dad
me too man but only one
yeah and what we were talking about the
other day and we're both huge fans of
you and we wanted to know
is when and how do we bring up our
previous
history with our daughters
hmm so they all have any idea
no how old are they
the oldest is four and a half okay then
we have two and a half
and then six weeks
oh gosh
you know can i
when did y'all just like have this when
did this come up
when did you think like when did you all
have the conversation you and your wife
like we're gonna have to tell our
daughters at some point
uh we've talked about in the past but
last week we were driving somewhere and
i think i was telling her about a show i
just listened to one of your shows and
i'm like hey we should probably think
about this
and another another aspect to this is we
actually last june had a miscarriage at
six weeks
and we also
have not brought that up so that's also
in the mix of kind of bringing up all
this
into the msa yeah
yeah you've got a lot
so
um man
broadly speaking
your kids
will not and i mean i wish there was a
nicer way to say this okay so just take
my blunt language here with a grain of
salt
um or take it with grace because i wish
there was a more graceful way to say
this
your kids will not have the baggage of
your past that you do
right their story will simply be
the story of their world which is both
of their parents were married to other
people who passed away
and so normally
i especially with a four and a half two
and a half it's one of those things that
if it comes up in natural conversation
well and here's a good example my
daughter's five she has been really
curious about like tell me another story
about when i was a baby or let's look at
pictures of me as a baby she wants to
know some of that history and she's five
or six that's about when i i think the
curiosity will
start um when did you and daddy meet
when was he your boyfriend when was she
your girlfriend um
and kids don't have
quite the same
not quite they don't have nearly the
same perception of time
and so
forever started when they
had consciousness consciousness does
that make sense so the idea that there
was a before them is weird and then when
they realized there was a before them
then there was
before y'all two were together
and then there was a like what you used
to date other people so the whole thing
is just like
their world expands like an accordion as
you all have these conversations and so
what i don't want you guys to do is feel
pressure that we have to have this big
grandiose conversation with them
and because they've got to know about
their past and their parents past they
got to know it and then all sudden you
use your needs
as use them as a proxy to get your needs
met which is i don't want to have these
secrets in our in my house
versus
when they come up then you have these
conversations
i will say that having some sort of
context for death is is good
whether that's a goldfish a grandparent
a pet
um
one of the most yeah we go ahead we had
a nate we had a neighbor uh
six months ago he passed away from covid
so i think she kind of gets an idea but
it's still
hard to gaze on whether she truly
understands like what death is so this
is a great great opportunity
to
you and your wife separately
together get with your daughter and say
hey we just want you to know that we've
been really sad that tim mr tim down the
street died
and your kid mate your daughter may ask
well what's died
or he'll come back
or
whatever that looks like
and
you can you let the her know
here's what grief looks like in a in a
way my friend rachel cruz says share
don't don't scare
in a way that she goes oh my parents
experience sad too
because then it humanizes
grief humanizes y'all it makes your
daughter one day when she feels grief
she won't feel crazy because she's got a
picture of it because she saw you guys
grief
and then you'll always have this anchor
point of death
so that when it comes up
when uh you and daddy
you know
uh when y'all
first got married or
what however the conversation goes right
i'm trying to pretend i'm a four and a
half year old and i'm there
psychologically but not you know what i
mean um
it will come up and that's when your
wife or you whoever gets this question
in in a non-dramatic way but in a
factual this is just our life this is i
got blonde hair i was at one time
married to somebody else and they died
remember like mr tim
my previous wife died and here's where
that can get scary for a kid you mean
mommy could die yeah she could
she probably won't
and every day we tell mommy we love her
she probably won't
but yeah we all die someday
and that's when the you get the
existential crisis between four to seven
years old and they start to realize oh
there was a before time oh there's gonna
be an after me too and it's you know you
may remember that from your childhood
and um
so it's just a part of their story
the greatest gift you can give your kids
though is to let them know that you're a
person and you get sad sometimes
it may be eight years is eight years do
you still have like a i don't know on
your on your first wife's birthday do
you you know do you go have a drink or
do you go out with buddy i mean do you
still
have seasons of sadness
uh yeah there's still definitely still
seasons especially
i would say the biggest ones around the
time whenever everything happened which
is you know coming up in a couple weeks
so yeah it was great so that might be
four and a half depending on your kid
feels a little bit early
um five and a half might not be
depending again my if my daughter if my
wife and i had the situation it wouldn't
be too early for my daughter but also
granted i'm kind of a weird dad and so
we talk about death a lot in my house
and so
her therapy bills and my sons are going
to be different later on down the road
um in some families it might not be
appropriate till seven or eight
or the poor family the other day that
shot one is a buddy of mine and his
daughter got a hold of the questions for
humans cards i have and found out santa
claus wasn't real and she's nine or ten
she found out from me right so
that might
oh yeah that's awesome so that might not
be you're gonna have to know your kid
but it might be
hey daddy's really sad today and i have
a story i have never told you but i have
a story i was married before mommy
i had a another wife
and she
was in a car wreck she got sick whatever
the story is and again you're talking a
30 000 foot story because she's five or
six
um
but
she passed away and like like mr tim she
died and
just once a year daddy gets really sad
and um when i get sad i like to be
around people that i love and i like to
write letters i like to hug and
sometimes i even cry
and it's that level of honesty and
vulnerability that is gonna i mean
you're talking legacy changing stuff
brother
like you're giving your daughters tools
that she will use for the rest of her
life
and she will ask harder questions and
it's it she will take your cue her her
cue from you and your wife as to are my
parents trustworthy can i ask them hard
questions are they safe to go to when
i'm scared or nervous
based on how you all answer those
questions you know what i mean
yep yeah
um i'm sorry that that's been your road
so far and i'm also really grateful that
y'all found each other and looks like
you all have created a beautiful life
yeah
it's yeah it's all part of god's plan
it's surreal though right like when you
sit down and look at the look at it
oh it really is do y'all ever have those
weird moments
oh yeah yeah can i can i can i
ask you one can i dig in for a second
sure i've had a couple of buddies in my
life whose spouse has passed away they
got remarried
and then they had kids
and the inevitable you know to drink
question is like
oh my gosh
the greatest things in my life were my
kids they wouldn't be here if the worst
thing in my life hadn't happened you
know what i mean you get this weird
existential loops have y'all have you
all had those conversations together
uh yeah we have
i think yeah
my wife brings that my wife brings that
up a lot she's
not helpful
so she'll just come over you know she'll
be sad and just be like excited and
happy because she's like you know
there was a point in my life where kids
are never in my future instead and now
look at us now we have these about the
time we haven't really talked about in
the last six weeks but we had this two
beautiful girls that are just amazing
and now we have three and i'm pretty
sure our family is complete now uh
but
fingers crossed it's quite a story yeah
so
here's what i would um
want to encourage you with
never keep secrets from each other
and
right
um
you can choose to not tell not to go
down those loop looping spirals
we've become obsessed in our culture
with the scientific meth like the
the asking hard questions and let's
follow the plan until we get to the
answer let's and the other thing we're
obsessed with is taking everything apart
at it to its smallest piece
if we can understand what makes up the
atom then we can understand what makes
up humanity and we can understand what
makes up the cause like we've that's
that's our current ethos
and so sometimes we want to know why why
did this happen and back it out here and
we can make ourselves crazy on these
reverse engineering explorations of our
life
right
and man what a gift just to say i don't
know but look at these three beautiful
girls now
you know what i mean
and our pain is a part of our story and
so is our joy
um
you're a gift my man i hope that helps
um
ultimately
this is a bad analogy have you all had
the sex talk yet at all with your
daughters
no no
by the way i'm looking forward to that
day either
[Laughter]
it'll come sooner than it'll come in the
most random you'll be in a target and
it'll be like oh
oh we're talking about tampons all right
i'm in
i'm in and you're gonna be ready to rock
and roll right um that happens
um but in a similar way
if we can have those conversations with
our daughters and with our sons and not
let them feel one iota of weirdness or
shame about their bodies
then they don't have weirdness and shame
about their bodies and if we don't have
weirdness and shame about our bodies
they don't they don't learn weirdness
and shame
similarly
if we
are
bold enough and courageous enough and
honest enough to understa like to speak
out death is part of this it's built
into the system here
we've made it this evil hush hush don't
talk about a thing and it's a part of
all of us
it's all of us right it's just the
operating instructions right
yeah how do we get into the miscarriage
side of things because i feel like
that's a slightly different discussion
with the whole you know there was a baby
in mommy's body and there wasn't and
just we weren't really sure how the
like we don't want to hold her from
them but we just don't know the best way
to approach that
yeah i i again if
if this was a week six
uh miscarriage and the kids didn't know
do they know that mommy was pregnant
no we hadn't told them yet okay that
might be something i'd hang on to and
because because again they're four and
two and
yeah babbling right
um i'd probably hang on to that um
and if
either of you have a season of grief
around that around that passing right
around that miscarriage then you let
your kids know that mommy's really sad
mommy's really sad
um daddy's really sad
and then over time that conversation
you'll have that conversation with your
daughters
and it would be
um
we've experienced multiple miscarriages
i got the names of
our
babies tattooed on my body and those are
conversations i've had with both of my
kids
but again they're a little bit older and
we talk we have a context of that type
of discussion in our house
and that's not for everybody at age five
or six or seven um but those
conversations will come
again that's setting up a
i'm willing to be vulnerable and tell
you about my life
not about you've got to know all the
things going on behind closed doors with
me and mom
you know what i mean
yep
did i remember hearing you say in a
previous episode there was about three
weeks before having this latest baby and
my wife was just very
overwhelmed with emotions and
like she's grieving you know losing that
one baby but now we're having this one i
could have swear i heard you say
something that's a natural body response
so
was i correct on that because that's why
i told her and she really was glad that
i've heard that from you but we just
wanted to kind of get clarification on
that about grief being a natural body
response
yeah it's like it like we were excited
because the baby was coming but she was
extremely sad because you know we have
lost the other baby
well you i mean
so you went through a terrible thing you
have this
grief
and then you get pregnant again
and that grief was devastating to your
body physically psychologically
spiritually your body felt that it
experienced it all of the stress
hormones and the lack of sleep and the
lack of nutrition and the lack of
intimacy all those things the isolation
so it puts a pin in that to use a
terrible
like google earth
analogy here
and then it remembers and the next time
she gets pregnant it sounds the alarms
hey remember last time look out look out
look out
you get what i'm saying a lot of that
yep and so what you have to do is to
recognize in a graceful curious way dude
my body's just trying to love me
and once your body recognizes oh no i
i'm in control
i appreciate it and i remember that too
and it was hard and it was terrible
that's why you hear me say it all the
time about writing letters what letters
caused us to do is to pause for an hour
or 30 minutes
and to think clearly write things down
look for evidence demand evidence of
these things
and to then
process and the whole time you're
breathing and you're slowing down and
you're being intentional and what you're
doing is you're telling your amygdala
hey we're still in control up here
we're good you don't need to run off and
set off every alarm we have set off the
anxiety alarms or the depression alarms
or whatever's going on
and then we can move on to the next
doesn't mean we're not sad doesn't mean
we're not
joy joyful about the new baby and sad
about the the baby that we lost we're
not it's not it's both in same time all
that's the same time and there's no
right or wrong way to do it but yeah
it's just most people fight their bodies
they want to shut off that sadness and
the sucky part is joy and sadness
they're on the same
they're on the same switch man
okay does that make you what i'm saying
so
feel them both they're both right
it's when one takes over
that you say maybe we need to go talk to
somebody when i just can't acknowledge
the joy of this new baby because i can't
get
the baby that we lost out of my head i
keep seeing the i keep reliving that
experience i keep reliving the
miscarriage i keep reliving the cramps i
keep reliving the headaches and the
crying it's when you can't stop and it
loops and your body gets stuck in that
loop loop loop that's when you go see a
professional but the okay
i hate this i'm weeping and at the same
time i'm holding this baby and laughing
and that's part of that's part of the
journey
okay
can i tell you this thank you
yeah those three girls are
won the dead lottery when they got you
well thank you like for real but
so my wife says too
she's lying to you she's supposed to say
that
i'm a podcast host i know but i'm just
kidding your wife's a genius she's knows
way more than my
idiot butt does whatever that's awesome
dude yeah you got a lot there man y'all
got a history of grief grief is a part
of your story
and so over time as your daughters dig
in and ask questions and ask to be
invited into your story
talk to them
share don't scare
but let them know yeah
death is a part of our life same with
the dogs and with the goldfish same with
our neighbor down the street mr tim
same with all of us
it's hard sheltering our kids from that
type of reality does nobody any good
you